I/O avoiding algorithms can be messy,
much messier than their conventional
RAM model counterparts, anyway.
But we started this lesson
by trying to argue that this
effort can be very worthwhile.
Remember the exercise where you looked
at potential reductions in I/Os
given realistic memory
hierarchy parameters?
You saw that there's a lot of
potential to make computations faster.
Now, this would happen if you could
make memory accesses contiguous and
exploit fast memory capacity to
the greatest extent possible.
And those wins can happen even if the
factors of improvement are only log L or
log Z, in the case of mergesort.
In closing this lesson,
let me make one final meta comment for
you to think about.
Our model assumes that the time
spent moving data dominates.
That means you should look for
ways to reduce I/Os.
But how do you know whether
data movement dominates?
In thinking about that question, let
me suggest that now is a good time for
you to pause, go back and revisit some
of our other high-level concepts,
like computational intensity and
machine balance.